well It Coats the pots you cook with so
the food doesn't stick it protects the
carpet your baby crawls on you may also
have it in your winter jacket your skin
lotion even your makeup we're talking
about Teflon American production has
become the most efficient in the world
and as a result all factories and
Industrial plants are turning out in
ever increasing amount of goods things
that people want and need your pot
research chemists develop a new and
unique white substance the result is the
greatest advanced in cookware
Teflon here are two different types of
fry pan this non-stick finish for
cookware never needs scouring all kinds
of burned food come off quickly and
easily horn muffins don't stick to
Teflon almost nothing sticks to it so
look for the Teflon 2 qualities look for
this seal look for the seal look for
this sticker well it sounds great but is
it really safe to cook in
these Teflon and Scotchgard chemicals
permeated the living world today every
baby is born with Teflon chemicals in
their blood C8 is one of the elements
they need to make Teflon pfos pifoa C8
these are all names for this group of
Miracle chemicals that came out of 3M
initially and out of DuPont they are
aware clearly aware of the risk of the
product their own documents show that
this is a toxin their studies were
showing rats dying dogs dying monkeys
dying they were saying testicular tumors
liver disease pancreatic disease
unfortunately monkeys even at the lowest
dose were dying after being exposed to
pfoa and they know that these primate
Studies have a direct relationship to
what we'll find in the human population
at one point Dupont came out and said if
your drinking water is showing more than
one part per billion of C8 then you
better not drink the water it's one drop
of C8 in an Olympic-sized pool how high
were your levels when they told you
about your water they're supposed to be
under 40 pots per trillion ours is 26
000. 26 000. we didn't know it at the
time but the evidence showed that 3M and
Dupont they knew all about it that
Dupont had knowingly poisoned us they
knew and they went ahead and did it
anyway
so you're at 3M in the 1940s you've
invented hundreds of new products over
the years but none of them have really
taken you to the stratosphere you're
looking for that one breakthrough
product the one thing that's going to
change everything for you and that's
when you discovered something big a
chemical called perfluic octinoic acid
or pfoa also known simply as c8s and C8
was special it was non-stick heat
[__] it was water resistant which
meant that this single chemical that you
discovered was gonna change consumer
goods forever some people use a little
oil or butter when they cook so that
things don't stick to the pan but I use
poly tetrafluora ethylene some sports
call it non-stick for short
hmm now that's cooking so you supplied
your ca2 Dupont another chemical company
and they use your ca to make Teflon a
new Wonder material that was put into
everything people buy everything from
pots and pans to fire extinguishers
waterproof clothes Furniture takeout
containers pizza boxes carpets
electronics and even dental floss all of
this contains some sort of Teflon and
that Teflon was made using c8s basically
you were able to get your grubby little
fingers into almost every single product
people interact with on a daily basis
which meant you became insanely rich but
there was just one small teeny tiny
problem C8 and all the other chemicals
you made like it are extremely toxic
we're talking like cancer causing birth
defects toxic I was originally born with
just one nostril limited Vision in my
right eye Bucky Bailey's mother worked
in the DuPont chemical plant in 1980 in
parkersville West Virginia making Teflon
the non-stick surface for pots and pans
what Bucky's mother didn't know at the
time was that she was exposed to a
chemical known as pfoa she was working
directly with the chemical while she was
pregnant with me the doctors they were
just completely scared they said don't
get your hopes up he won't make it
through the night and you said your mom
is now suffering illnesses herself she
is she has a thyroid disease which is
linked to the chemical one exposure
chemical exposure yes which meant that
if anyone found out about just how toxic
C8 was your breakthrough product your
Ace in the Hole will be no more losses
will come pouring in the billions would
stop flowing so you were left with only
one logical option intentionally hide it
from the public so pressure fighting is
about c8s you want to make your billions
first then worry about the consequences
later by then you'll have so much money
and power that a few lawsuits here and
there won't even matter today we finally
know that C8 is linked to all sorts of
diseases like kidney cancer thyroid
disease testicular cancer and a whole
host of other terrible things but it's
too late because 99.7 of Americans
already have C8 in their bloodstream
they are found in every one of you prior
to 1977 perfluorinated materials had
been found in in human blood at first 3M
and Dupont were checking to see the
contamination levels of their workers
and so naturally they needed to compare
those workers blood levels of CA with
the population so they could see what
the difference was so they started going
to archived blood supplies and checking
to see what clean blood versus the blood
of their workers might look like there
was no clean blood they tested kids they
tested adults they went to Asia they
went all over the world and everywhere
they looked practically they found their
chemicals in people's blood eventually
they did find some clean blood it turned
out it was the blood that had been taken
from army recruits and archived saved at
the start of the Korean war that blood
was clean because the Teflon chemicals
weren't out into the environment at that
point yes you watching this right now
probably have this forever chemical in
your body and there's nothing you can do
to get it out well 3M by poisoning the
world forever 3M is now one of the
largest most powerful conglomerates in
the world and they barely even got a
slap on the wrist for it
they called this fluorine chemical the
devil's piss it was so potent sunlight
doesn't break them down microbes don't
break them down heat doesn't break them
down nothing breaks them down a lot of
chemicals when they go into your body or
when they end up in the environment they
break down they slowly decompose pfas
don't do that once you put pfast
somewhere it's going to stay there
practically forever they are nearly
indestructible
if you've been hurt by a big corporation
like 3M you gotta sue them because as
you're going to see later in this video
they have more than enough money to pay
you but the problem is lawsuits cost a
lot of money but luckily that is where
this law firm called Morgan and Morgan
comes in Morgan and Morgan is a law firm
that actually just won a giant case
against the realm recently what's
special about Morgan and Morgan is that
you only pay if they win your case
that's right you can have America's
largest injury Law Firm fighting for you
for zero dollars out of pocket and
they've got over 800 expert lawyers in
almost every practice area imaginable
from class actions to defective products
data breaches workplace discrimination
all the way to personal injury cases
where 100 plus offices Nationwide so
however you've been injured whether it
be by a big corporation like 3M or in a
car accident Morgan and Morgan can help
but because they only get paid if they
win they do have to be selective about
the cases they bring on so if you want
to find out if they can take your case
all you have to do is pause the video
scroll down and click the link below to
go to for the people.com there you'll be
able to submit your claim in as little
as eight clicks or less without ever
leaving your couch so pause the video
scroll down and click the link below to
go to Florida people.com Jake Trent to
submit your case now thanks to Morgan
and Morgan for sponsoring this video
foreign
1902 five businessmen founded the
Minnesota Mining and Manufacturing
company or 3M for shorts originally 3M
was supposed to be a mining company but
the land they were going to mine turned
out to have zero potential at all
it was your first big mistake the first
of many for a company that would
eventually become known for being built
are mistakes but this was the early
1900s it was the age of innovation
everyone was inventing new and useful
stuff like vacuum cleaners Neon Lights
plastic and even tea bags in fact most
of the modern conveniences we enjoyed
today were being created during this
time and you've won it in so you gave up
on your money operation and set up shop
as a research company and the first
thing you produced sandpaper out of all
things around the same time a guy named
William mcknights started working for
your company as an assistant bookkeeper
and this would be bookkeeper would end
up changing your company forever in his
first few years McKnight flew up the
ranks he became a general manager of 3M
and that's where the big changes started
3m's second biggest mistake was leaking
olive oil onto almost all sandpaper and
inadvertently still selling it to
customers when people started getting
angry about finding olive oil on their
sandpaper it gave McKnight an idea
sandpaper that could be used either wet
or dry and he ran with it with the help
of an outside year you s3m started
selling wet or dry sandpaper in 1921 it
was her first successful product and it
made you hungry for more after the
Sandpaper breakthrough making mistakes
became company policy according to a 3M
executive back then every idea should
have a chance to prove sport if it is
good we want it and if it is not good we
will have purchased peace of mind when
we have proved it impractical next on
your list of inventions was Scotch tape
which was first used to paint two-tone
cars it had to be strong enough to stick
to the car but not so strong that it
pulled paint off the body and Scotch
tape became another big success Post-it
notes reflective signs and a dozen other
inventions quickly followed but nothing
really made you stand out everyone
everywhere was inventing stuff so you
weren't exactly special or better than
the rest what you really wanted was to
create an invention so useful so
valuable that it would be used in
everything and you finally got that
chance in 1947.
[Music]
thank you in 1938 a doctor named Roy
Plunkett accidentally discovered Teflon
and it changed the world forever Teflon
was non-stick waterproof and could take
a lot of heat which made it useful for a
lot of things but there was just one
problem Dr Plunkett made this discovery
working for Dupont at the time not you
and in 1947 Dupont was much bigger
richer and better known than you ever
were there was no way you could ever
compete with them but you didn't give up
see creating Teflon is not an easy
process it takes a lot of very specific
difficult to produce chemicals and that
is where you saw your chance see if you
can Mass produce the chemicals needed to
make Teflon before do pot code instead
of competing with Dupont you can make
billions working alongside duponts
supplying them with the ingredients they
needed for their best selling products
so your scientists got to work in 1947
you officially discovered this
also known as pfoa or c8s pfoa was just
one of a whole bunch of forever
chemicals that you managed to create but
it was the only one that really mattered
because by 1951 Dupont was buying
truckloads of C8 from you to produce all
his Teflon products
good thing it's Teflon coupon
CA changed everything for 3M you became
a multi-million dollar company selling
one of the most sought after chemicals
on the planets but then just a few years
after creating c8s your scientists made
a horrifying Discovery a discovery that
you had to suppress at all costs
[Music]
by the 1960s C8 was everywhere it was
this new Wonder chemical that no one
could get enough of but there was just
one problem producing CA in Teflon
created a lot of C8 waste that you
needed to get rid of somewhere but
properly disposing of a harsh chemical
like C8 is expensive so Dupont just
Delta into rivers and unprotected
landfills after all there was no proof
at the time that C8 was harmful to
anyone people were literally using it to
cook their food how could it ever be
toxic but as soon as you heard that
Dupont was ducking C8 into the
environments you had your suspicions
sure there was no proof at the moment
that CE was toxic but that's because no
one ever ran any test to see if C8 was
harmful in the back of your mind you
knew that dumping C8 into the
environment was probably gonna spell
trouble but the money was just too good
so you just turned the Blind Eye no need
to investigate so for the next decade
you said nothing and did nothing while
hundreds of thousands of pounds of C8
was being dumped into the Earth it
didn't matter that around the same time
Dupont was secretly running experiments
on the effects of c8s and found that it
caused all sorts of defects in rats
rabbits and dogs but luckily Dupont was
on the same boat as you and also kept
their mouth shuts for more than a decade
after your first suspicions it was
business as usual so CA and Teflon kept
seeping into every aspect of Our Lives
from the clothes we were to the things
we eat with but as the years went on
your curiosity got the better of you the
bigger your company grew the more you
realize that you needed to know the
truth before someone else figured it out
that way if your little secret ever got
exposed you would at least know enough
to do some damage control so by the
early 1970s you secretly test a group of
scientists to start running tests on
fish found in a river contaminated with
c8s and what you found was absolutely
terrifying
[Music]
thank you
see it wasn't just getting into the fish
and damaging their health but C8 was
accumulating in the fish in other words
unlike other toxic chemicals CA wasn't
breaking down once it entered their
bodies it kind of just stayed there
becoming more and more concentrated over
time and it only got worse from there
around the same time you were testing
River fish internal documents from both
3M and Dupont show that you guys knew C8
was highly toxic when inhaled and
moderately toxic when adjusted by as
early as 1970 but you were In Too Deep
by now Teflon products have found
themselves in every single household in
America it has spread all over the world
already it was used in airplanes and
cars on and on the applications were
endless I found that these chemicals
couldn't Bond paper products to make
food wraps grease proof wraps cookie
bags so if the world found out now you
would be sued into Oblivion so you did
the only thing you could think of you
buried the evidence when Dupont
employees started having miscarriages or
babies with birth defects you and Tupac
get quiet about it while quietly moving
the female employees of child
away from CA exposure exposure to C8
also increased the size of the liver and
wraps rabbits and dogs and if it had
this effect on animals who knows what
kind of effect it was causing on humans
then the realm found that pfoas cause
birth defects in rats you share this
fighting with Dupont they took a look at
their private employees and what did
they find two out of seven babies were
born with eye defects and from there the
findings just got worse and worse and
worse but all you could do was keep
suppressing it you even went so far as
the pay respected University professors
to write papers saying C8 was not toxic
you also blocked any papers that
mentioned C8 in a negative light from
ever being published and even when your
own employees started getting sick and
developing cancer you said nothing but
deep down you knew this game couldn't go
on forever and by the 1990s your time
finally came independent scientists
started publishing reports on the
possible toxic effects of c8s and you
decided that now was the time to get out
while you still could
thank you
[Music]
foreign
you pretended that you had just found
out about how Bassy it was and you
handed over the hundreds of studies you
had done on C8 while also publicly
announcing that you would stop producing
forever chemicals for good you look like
the good guy coming clean as soon as you
found out the bad news and it worked it
worked so well that even the EPA got
fooled saying that three and deserves
great credit for identifying this
problem and coming forward voluntarily
sure you had known about the harmful
effects of ca for more than 25 years but
no one else needed to know that and the
eyes of the world you were the honest
caring whistleblower who risked your own
profits to tell the truth so who did the
EPA ended up blaming while your old pal
Dupont of course you came forward and
threw Dupont under the bus and as a
result Dupont got publicly smeared they
were made Public Enemy Number One while
3M you never even really got mentioned
in the C8 lawsuits as more than a
footnote it was a brilliant move you had
spent decades making billions selling
toxic chemicals to the world and here
you were walking away blame free after
you dropped C8 you could have gone clean
it could have kept on a straight and
narrow but old habits die hard and it
didn't take long for you to get involved
in yet another cover-up a cover-up that
threatened to undo everything you got
away with
foreign
[Music]
bought out a military supply company
called Aero Technologies one of the
products Aero Technologies produced were
double ended earplugs soldiers could use
to protect their hearing while shooting
but there was just one small problem you
knew the earplugs you were selling were
defective they kind of really protect
soldiers the way you advertised but what
was one more life that the public really
gonna do come on you got away with
literally poisoning the entire world
there was no way a couple of defective
earplugs could make it any worse or so
you thoughts within months soldiers
started reporting hearing loss and other
problems the earplugs were supposed to
prevent but unlike the effects of c8s a
soldier becoming deaf can easily be
linked to the earplugs they were using
which meant that you were screwed in
2018 you had to pay 9.1 million dollars
to settle the lawsuits the soldiers
brought against you which is literally
chump change for you and for a second
you thought that you had gotten away
with it but you overlooked one small
detail after C8 you were supposed to
stay under the radar to avoid making
waves but this earplug Scandal was the
exact opposite suddenly everyone's eyes
were on this patriotic company that was
knowingly selling our American warriors
defective equipment and that opened up
the floodgates suddenly people started
digging up all the old 3M reports on C8
and started seeing all the lies you have
been telling the public over the years
and by June 2023 the first of 4 000
pending lawsuits against 3M started in
South Carolina it accuses 3M of allowing
forever chemicals in New Or toxic to
leak into Municipal Water Supplies if
this lawsuit succeeded it would have
cost 3M up to 143 billion dollars in
cleanup costs alone almost triple is
worth but in reality 3M ended up
settling for just 12.5 billion dollars
which they'll make back after just two
years of profit just two years of profit
in exchange for poisoning the entire
world but this is progress because as
we've mentioned this is just one of
those 4 000 lawsuits and guess what the
attorneys behind the settlement are from
Morgan and Morgan today's video sponsor
oh
and if Morgan and Morgan can take on 3M
they can probably take on your case too
imagine what they can do for you if
you've been hurt by a big Corporation or
even a car accident for example luckily
Morgan and Morgan would not charge you a
dime unless they win your case but you
gotta reach out to them which is super
easy all you gotta do is scroll down
click the link below to go to for the
people.com and you'll be able to submit
a claim in eight clicks or less without
ever having to leave your couch so click
the link below to go before the
people.com to start your claim now
thanks to Morgan and Morgan for
sponsoring this video
but you want to know what's even
sketchier than 3M the food pyramid ah
yes you know the food pyramid well as it
turns out the food they put on the food
pyramid was never about your health no
no it was about who brought the
government with the most money but I
think the more kosher term is called
lobbying ah yes America's food pyramid
was simply sold to the highest bidder
why else do you think cereal out of all
things is such a big part of the pyramid
when John Kellick literally designed
cornflakes to kill your sex drive and we
expose it all in our new documentary on
our new Channel evil food supply that
you can watch by clicking the card on
the screen right now because as we
always say health is not wealth health
is the only thing you've got and big
food and big government seem to be
trying their damn this to keep you fat
and addicted so click the card on the
screen to watch our documentary on the
food pyramid now
foreign